okay so for anybody out there who's
unaware Nick a30 is a popular
fortnight's streamer who got between
seven and twelve thousand average
monthly viewers on Twitch after signing
with that platform back in September he
also happens to have 4.6 million YouTube
subscribers now Nick is like the squeaky
clean
boy from next door on Twitch his stream
is family-friendly it's PG he doesn't
swear and this weekend he kind of
cheated in fortnight at a charity event
okay so this weekend twitch and the
Super Bowl collaborated for eight which
rivals event that paired NFL players
with well-known or famous fortnight's
streamers and content creators maybe you
watched it me I was too busy watching
faze clan dominate csgo and twenty20
baby cold with everything to do to spot
big noggins he's cleared three parties
okay back to twitch rivals at the
Superbowl there were 32 players 16 duo's
and 4 games for them to play now how did
Nick a30 cheat did he install an aimbot
no did he use map hacks he dropped where
he wasn't supposed to basically the
rules for this event stated that you
could only drop in very specific
condensed areas of the map so that all
32 players weren't spread across an
entire fortnight map to be playing some
P oh I hot drop so there's only 16 duo's
and we kind of want the game to have
some intensity right off the bat so
we've instructed all the players to drop
on these particular locations for each
of the games the reason for this is
pretty obvious 32 players is about a
third of the number of the normal
participants in a given fortnight map so
if you let them drop wherever they want
we're basically going to be watching a
walking simulator now Game three of this
four game event is where the rule
bending takes place Nick a 30 and his
partner David Morgan drop outside the
designated zone
now the reason why this would be a
competitive advantage is obvious you get
access to uncontested Luth you're going
to be coming
players from a direction that they don't
expect you to be coming at them from and
for the first moments of the game you
know you're gonna be relatively safe
because nobody's gonna be looking at
that area now conceivably could they
have dropped a little outside the zone
by accident of course unfortunately for
Nick he was caught on stream
strategizing about doing just that
dropping purposely outside the zone
noting to his partner that if they did
so they would just get a warning and
telling him it can't be that obvious
there's no real good like pew lies that
are nearby that's the only problem so
yeah so I think what we wanted to know
so did breaking the drop rules actually
in practice
give him a competitive edge well it
definitely seems like it since he was
able to catch Team Liquid fortnight pro
chaff and his partner totally off guard
and killed them in the opening moments
of the match
papa
where to think that sucks I didn't hear
them at all where they come from on
chaps own stream you can clearly see how
surprised he is after getting killed by
someone who just shouldn't be there
later watching Nikkei 30 stream back
chap concludes that he dropped way
outside the zone and that he and his
partner were killed by somebody who
straight-up wrote the rules was that and
maybe still a house it was in oh wait no
it definitely isn't oh that's lame
it definitely landed like really far
outside of the zone then rotated in that
second place and died worth noting here
guys that as of this recording Nick a30
has private in the vaad of his stream of
this event so at this point it is cut
and dry that Nick a30 knew the rules and
willingly broke them to get a tactical
advantage but the question is is it
actually cheating or is it bending the
rules is it doing whatever you need to
do to get the W people aren't really
pissed about this and I think part of
the reason is because of the persona
that Nick a30 has when he streams this
guy is family friendly he is positive he
is PG if you're a mom and your kid is
super into fortnight you want him or her
watching Nick a 30 and not say t Fuu hey
you ever won it is Nick day 30 here and
welcome to my channel Alexa play
oh my god
Alexa pause but manipulating the rules
at a charity event just isn't in line
with the person that Nick a30 presents
himself as on street he's also accused
other people of bending the rules or
cheating in the past like when he went
at CLG content creator and player
marksman for supposedly doing with a guy
impersonating the guy he was supposed to
pair with which turned out not to be
true at all at the end of the day are we
talking about Jarvis level cheating here
no is this guy gonna get the equivalent
of fortnight vac banned probably not but
when the words cheating and charity
tournament come together that's just not
a good look it's 2020 phase clay and his
back baby
Nico is back baby rain is back bro key
is back he never left he's new so that
doesn't make any sense
Olaf is back cold is Ella back it's a
good time to be a counter-strike fan to
come over to my side no not a good time
to be a four-night fan great time to be
a counter-strike fan you gotta come over
to the the real shooter